Can you hear me?
Oh, yeah, sorry.
I moved my mic yesterday, and so I couldn't...
This is my first time hearing me speak this morning.
So I was like, oh, my voice...
Oh, I just woke up.
Hello.
Sounds windy.
Don't blow away, Minto.
That was weird.
That was a little silly.
Look back.
Thanks.
Do you guys mind if I make some tea real quick?
Is it okay?
Is it okay if I make some tea real quick?
Shouldn't take long to boil.
I should have probably done this sooner.
Is the wind really loud?
No.
I'll allow it.
Okay, everybody, Nathaniel said that he allows it, so...
I think that's all the permission I need.
Okay, BRB.
But I'll still talk.
I won't mute.
I
walked out of my room yesterday when I was leaving.
I was leaving my hotel, and I was like...
Like, last minute, I was like, oh, my gosh, I'm gonna actually change bags.
Because I was like, I don't want to bring my big...
Or rather, I was like, I want a bag that zips up, you know?
And...
So I went back to my room, and it's one of those, like...
It's an electric, you know?
I mean, well, I guess that's how most locks are now, huh?
But when I would...
When I would do the beep-boop...
It would unlock, but I couldn't open...
I would hear the lock go...
But then it wouldn't open the door.
Ahem.
I've been really busy with work, and I'm...
It's currently nearing 42C.
Send help.
I'm gonna be on VOD duty for the next few...
Few months?
Saku!
Noooo!
Well, thanks for still watching the VOD.
If you can.
Don't...
You know, no pressure.
If you're too busy, I get it.
You know?
I get it.
See you later.
Just leave a comment, so I know you're still...
Alive.
I guess.
That's how that works.
Well, I guess if you die too...
Leave a comment as a ghost.
Please buy Wendy's with this.
Oh my gosh, I wanted Wendy's the other day.
Because Wendy's in Japan is not just Wendy's.
It's Wendy's first kitchen.
I love fucking.
And it's...
So it's just so...
But the menu is a little bit different.
The fries are...
Are...
Um...
They have a...
What's the word?
A...
You can choose what kind of flavor fries you want.
So there's like...
Cheese flavor...
Or soy sauce flavor...
And it's basically...
Yeah.
Fa...
King.
First kitchen.
What did you guys think I said?
Fa...
King.
First kitchen.
It's the cool way to shorten it, everybody.
Gosh.
My contribution to Wendy's first kitchen fund.
No, no, no.
The reason I didn't go was because I had food poisoning.
I was like...
Oh my gosh.
I should not go to another burger place.
What's all these gifted all of a sudden?
ViviCore, thank you.
S1, thank you for the 20.
Motsu, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
My water's done boiling.
Hold on.
Open.
Thanks for the five gifted.
I don't like gifted memberships.
I only like skippity toilet.
Do, welcome to membership.
Wow, what's up?
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you, guys.
Teacup, thanks for the five gifted.
No more.
Mint.
Wait up.
Thank you for the five gift.
Thank you guys so much.
Have a boy.
No more.
I don't want any more.
Give us a nice dancer.
I don't need my escape any time now.
Thank you for the 50, Captain!
Holy moly, thank you!
Stop negative two!
Stop it!
Why can't you guys just love me for who I am?
This is so wrong.
Stop it!
Stop it, please!
Maple, not you!
Tuna, not you guys both!
Stop it!
This is so mean.
Anyway, welcome to We Harvest Shadows.
Which is a demo.
As you can see, it says, We Harvest Shadows Demo.
I love this note at the bottom.
I'm away at Gamescom now.
So if you run into any serious issues, let me know.
Fun Comics, thanks for the time!
I just got another new Ace Combat Jacket.
Wait, where?
Oh, I can't show you because of spoilers.
Where though?
Get loved harder, idiot.
Shut up, Ashes!
I don't want to hear that from you!
Oh my gosh, Tri-Princess, thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Demo, what?
Demo.
It's a demo.
Oh my god, that Ace.
Thank you for the time, Captain!
Thank you!
It's a demo!
But this game looks actually like really promising.
It looks really good.
I don't know.
Maybe it's not like something that a lot of VTubers have been touching on.
So maybe some people don't know about it.
Scarlet Broke, thank you for the five gift cards!
Did you happen to see the Minecraft movie trailer?
Wait, no!
Wait, they actually put up a trailer?
No way.
KZ, thanks for the gift card!
You can appreciate it.
I can appreciate it.
Shut up.
Phantom!
Thanks for the gift card!
Wait, should I watch it real quick?
Hashtag Black.
I know!
It's bad.
Wait, it's kinda cringe, but it looks pretty.
Should I do a live reaction?
Thank you!
Chuu!
Got you!
Oh, you're fast!
You got it!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, hold on.
Okay, hold on.
I want to turn off the sound.
Okay, I'm going to turn off the sound because also, since it's like a trailer...
I don't know.
I feel like Minecraft would try and copyright strike me, right?
Okay, this is my live reaction.
Sorry, hold on.
Let me type a thing up.
First reacting to a Minecraft movie.
Reacting...
Oh, first reacting to Minecraft movie trailer.
That's why the sound is off.
We'll put it right there.
And then we'll talk...
I want to talk more about this game though.
Okay, Minecraft movie.
I'm going to have all the wind blowing and stuff.
But, you know.
Agreed.
Minto needs all the love.
Even if she's skibbity.
Minus two.
Shut up.
Did she hear about any bracelet from Vishojo?
Bracelet?
Passed it along at Vexpo.
I don't think I've gotten any Vexpo.
I don't...
I don't think Vexpo was able to...
I don't know if they were able to accept gifts.
I didn't have anyone accepting...
I will ask them.
Okay, Minecraft movie teaser.
I'm watching now.
Oh, a little...
Little square and turning into...
Oh, the Beatles.
Oh, no.
No, no.
They're doing that, like, stereotypical trailer thing.
Oh, it looks really weird seeing real people in the Minecraft area.
It's like an actual child.
Okay.
They're doing, like, that thing.
Oh, the sheep look so ugly.
Yeah, they're doing, like, the...
Oh, my gosh.
This is so stereotypical.
This is what, like, people make fun of, like, trailers for.
Oh, my gosh.
The little tiny wood in the middle of the wood.
Oh, the creeper.
The creepers look pretty cute, though.
I'm not going to lie.
Ah!
Jack, fuck!
Is this supposed to be, like, Minecraft a long time, like, when Steve grows up and stuff?
What is this dialogue?
Actually, I'm very confused about what is...
Huh?
The piglins all just run past and the little llamas, like...
Oh, April 4th.
That's a spooky day.
Wow, that was a trailer, you guys.
Oh!
I...
Oh...
Oh, gosh.
Block...
Game for block brain.
Um...
It looks very pretty, like people said.
Why are there, like, four extra people?
And they're all insufferable.
I don't know anything about them.
I thought it was...
I thought Jack Black was going to be, like, the main character, right?
Like...
I thought that, like, he would...
I thought that he would be, like, Steve going on an adventure.
Right?
Why are there extra people?
Oh, no.
Feels Jumanji-esque.
Maybe.
Is it an Isekai?
It looks like it.
Minecraft meets Jumanji.
Hmm...
Ah...
Oh, I guess we'll see.
I don't know.
It might get Sonic-movied, you guys.
You know, people might just be like, Yo, this ain't it.
And they're like, okay.
Redo!
We'll see.
André goes next to the Tony Gifton!
Yeah, we'll see.
Though, honestly...
Please.
I want them to release the ugly Sonic movie so bad.
I want that.
Just like how I want Butthole Cat.
Just release it.
Like, the world kind of wants this, right?
Right!
Like...
Just to experience it.
What we could have had.
Maybe it's like Overlord where Jack Black fell asleep playing Minecraft and woke up in the game.
Maybe.
Like, I see some people being like, Why didn't he, like, you know, cut his hair?
Like, why didn't he look the part of Steve?
But maybe it's like a, I'm Steve.
I've been in the game...
Forever.
You know...
I'm...
I've...
I've just been here.
I'm Wild Steve.
I'm Wild Steve!
You know?
Give us the true cat.
Release the call of the wild with the man instead of the CG doc.
Okay, I don't know what that's referencing.
Anyway.
That was exciting.
Thank you for first Minecraft movie trailer.
Reaction.
Real time.
Hashtag release the Butthole Cut.
Phantom 2024.
This game...
Is like...
A farm simulator.
But it's also quite spooky.
Um...
It's a demo.
So it's not very long.
But it's also quite several hours long.
I don't think I'm gonna be able to complete the demo.
Um...
Because...
Did you like how they had to put both a sheep chewing to start and an end with a llama chewing?
Just to show how funny quirky the movie is.
Also cats 2019 watch along.
You promised.
I did promise all those years ago.
You try and not know about those things.
Cjdog vs.
Jpegsdog.
Oh my gosh, they've been so funny.
Oh -o.
They finally got corpse andraik too.
That's better than downhill.
I don't know if you hear this.
One, two, three!
I am going with the best but.
Friends!
Oh my gosh, I'm meeting with friends!
And we're gonna go do some fun girly stuff.
So I'm excited about that.
And I touched grass yesterday too.
Actually, Matara and I went to Disney Sea.
And we had a lot of fun.
And we'll talk about it later so that we can actually have stuff to talk about.
But you know how much I love Indiana Jones.
So you know.
Yeah.
But I also got to ride some stuff I had never ridden before.
So I was very excited.
It was just such nice weather.
Not a lot of people.
It's kind of perfect.
Touching grass, Tex.
Start new game!
Since I don't have so much time since I'm meeting with people in a couple of hours.
I shall start the game and play.
Let's go.
Those eyes.
That demonic face.
Me?
In the rearview mirror.
Rearview mirror?
That's when it all started.
Wait, I'm covering the subtitles.
It was the morning after everything went down.
There's a face in the mirror?
I didn't have anyone anymore.
I'm scared.
I got into my mom's old truck to drive back to New York like I always do.
But something happened that I can't explain.
What happened?
I saw my exit, turned on the blinker, and drove right past it.
Oh, okay.
Oh, wait, there?
It sounds crazy, but I physically could not turn the wheel.
Oh my god.
Because I have no hands!
Sorry, there is a face in the mirror.
Oh my god.
Sorry, that scared me.
I was in a rush to nowhere.
So I drove, empty-headed and exhausted.
Wow, it's actually so beautiful.
That's when I saw it.
It felt like the only right thing to happen to me in years.
Someone in my car!
Wait, it's only a two-seater!
How is there someone in the back?
I locked the gate and left everyone behind.
It would cost me everything I had, but I needed solitude.
His voice is so good.
Oh, I can jump.
Oh.
So I bought the farm.
There was a farm?
I did lock the gate, and I did throw away the key as hard as I could.
Bye, key!
I started laughing out of sheer joy.
When was the last time that I laughed?
I couldn't believe I was actually doing it.
The music is so nice.
Why is my car covered in leaves?
You made me a promise, Garrick, you older woman.
Oh, sorry.
I'm blocking the subtitles.
I'm so sorry.
What's going on?
It's probably not what you expected, but I'm going to keep that promise, mom.
Should I run?
I'm running.
Where's
my house?
So I bought a farm.
Um, yep.
I did that.
What's going on?
The music is a bit loud.
I'm gonna turn it down some, yeah.
Day one.
The unseen wanderer.
All right, Garrick.
Today's the day.
You're gonna leave the house.
Oh, boy!
Hold your paws, everyone.
Where did I put that to-do list?
Oh!
If I can find it in all this garbage.
I have a journal.
This one?
Read?
Um, press right click.
Oh, press F to use your flashlight.
Oh, my gosh!
This is my house!
This is where I'm living?
This has black mold all over it.
I'm trying to...
I'm pressing right click, but nothing's working.
Why can't I read it?
Why do I have leaves in my house?
Why am I living like this?
Do I have like a battery?
Most of these times, these games have like a battery, you know?
It's...
Right click is...
Oh, wait.
Is it left click?
Oh, my God.
Well, TV would have been nice with a whole being alone for everything.
Oh, okay.
Thanks to remember.
Check my to-do list every day.
Don't forget to use tools.
There should be some laying around the house.
I can buy more in the mail order catalog.
Get to bed on time.
These woods give me the creeps.
Drop things in the trailer to sell them.
Tree logs are worth a few cents, but tomatoes and chicken eggs are more...
Much more valuable.
Okay.
Sorry, guys.
I didn't realize...
It was left click.
But the right click was the one that was highlighted, okay?
My ultimate goal should be buying the rifle.
But I'll work on my to-do list for the first few days and save up some cash.
This is the rest of my life now.
Forever alone in the best way possible.
However, I did send one letter after buying this place.
He's the only one who has my address.
I wonder when he'll get here.
Okay.
Look.
I...
I have all this dirt.
Oh!
The sun is rising!
What a beautiful day!
I need to find my to-do list first.
Okay.
Where is that?
In here?
Oh.
My clothes.
Nothing but the clothes on my back, huh?
Oh, gross.
Why are we stuffing our...
Why are we keeping our stuff in here?
This is...
Where...
To...
Oh!
There's my to-do list.
Phew.
Okay.
My to-do list is...
Essential.
Press tab to view my tasks.
Okay.
He wears JPEGs.
Tasks marked with an asterisk are required to progress the story.
Completing an optional or required task usually earns you money as well.
You can view...
Look at this!
Okay.
I'm sorry.
But if you see the...
That...
Doesn't it look like right click?
The right part is like so much more dominating than the left one, right?
View your money and important items at the bottom of the...
Notepad.
Oh, I'm blocking it.
Now, time for the greatest dopamine release possible.
Cleaning your room and scratching it off your to-do list.
All right.
Okay.
Hold on.
Pause game.
Let's see.
How do I want to move myself?
I might have to be in a box, you guys.
Wait.
Oh, but everything's on like the right left side.
I might have to go to the right side, everybody.
Actually, what if I just...
Oh my gosh.
I'm going to do a real YouTuber thing.
I'm going to put...
myself in the corner.
I'm going to put myself in the corner, you guys.
With my big face.
Wow.
I'm a YouTuber.
I'm in the corner.
Mental reaction corner.
Wait, what was it?
Okay.
Pick up trash in the bedroom and throw it in the trailer.
All right, baby.
Baby.
Buy a watering can.
Oh, when I'm holding it, I like can't move.
Buy a watering can and water six tomato plants.
All right.
Let's pick up this trash.
All these leaves.
Oh, yeah.
Carry.
Oh my gosh.
We're the best cleaners ever.
There's this trash too.
Pick it up.
Pick it.
Pick.
Where's the...
Oh.
There.
This is heavy.
It's heavier than it looks.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Trailer.
Oh, our whole place is...
It's lighting up.
Hold on.
We gotta go find a thing first.
The trailer.
This is where we...
What we bought.
Trailer.
Over here.
Man, it's pretty here.
Not a soul for miles.
Wow.
I should have done this years ago.
I also...
Drop it.
Okay.
That wasn't bad.
Maybe I can get these tomatoes watered and then I'll be done.
Toot.
I also turned the graphics down because I'm on my laptop.
But...
Wow.
Look at our little...
area.
It's not so bad.
Looks fine for a laptop.
Yeah.
I'm just saying it could look even better.
What else we got around here?
I got stamina at the bottom.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Hot damn.
This doesn't even look that old.
Hot dag.
I could totally fix this up with the right parts.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
Let's also...
Sorry.
Audio.
Let's do music volume like half that.
Replace copyrighted songs.
Oh my gosh.
Thank goodness.
I saw that.
That should be better.
Was this the front door?
This is where I eat and sleep.
Well, then I have like a little speck on my laptop and it's making me think it's like my middle cursor.
So now we buy a watering can?
How do I buy?
But also this was glowing, wasn't it?
I don't remember this being here.
The painting.
Keep an eye on the mysterious painting of the hallway.
It will change in subtle and sometimes not so subtle ways to signify your mental state and alert you to danger.
The more horrifying the painting, the more danger you are in.
The painting.
Oh, there's like something.
There's like people staring at me.
Do you see that?
There's like people staring at me through the hallway.
Ew, I don't like that.
Ok, so it's slightly horrifying right now.
What's this?
Oh, a map of the area?
Looks like it's missing some pages.
Map and compassion.
Spooky!
Access your map by holding Q.
But you will first need to visit lookout towers.
Ohhh!
So that's what that was over there.
If you have found all items in a certain location, a checkmark will be added to the icon.
Oh!
Oh, that was over there!
No in-game waypoint markers, so be sure to slow down, study your map, and plan your next move with resolve.
Okay, so, um, everybody who's lost, that sucks for you.
Oh, no, no, no.
Go away.
Okay.
Interesting.
Our little... oh, that's a lot of...
That's a lot of beans!
Cans of beans as far as the eye can see.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Cool.
We're covered, everybody.
What's in here?
I have a feeling we're not showering.
You can flush the toilet.
Awesome.
Did I just hear, like, the toilet even, like, reload?
That's crazy.
So how do I buy a watering can?
He said, like, over here, right?
Or something?
Oh, what's this?
This is the catalog.
Yes, yes, yes.
We have a dollar!
Buy.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, and here.
Here's our hold.
Oh, okay.
That worked.
Okay.
Easy.
Easy peasy.
Okay.
Awesome.
We did it!
Oh my gosh, we got a dollar!
You can go to bed early if you complete your to-do list.
Well, it did say...
It wasn't a lot, but it was something.
I better get to bed.
One day down, eternity to go.
Oh!
What was that?
Who keeps knocking on something?
There's, like, a pounding.
Gosh, maybe this was a bad idea.
I'm so scared in my hotel room.
At least when I'm home, I'm with, like, my cats.
But, like...
You know...
The ghost.
Sorry, that was me.
Stop!
Why am I going to bed so early?
I just woke up.
There's so much more to explore and see and everything.
Can I leave?
I want to see what's over there.
Okay.
Why did we buy this place?
Why was this even for sale?
This looks abandoned, you know?
What else can I buy?
Let's see.
I guess it is starting to get, like...
Oh!
Carry?
We got some stones?
Can I sell these?
Oh my gosh!
They're worth 10 cents!
Collect the stones!
Oh my gosh.
We're going to go crazy spending spree here.
$20.
Okay.
I want the axe.
Oh, $15?
Okay.
We're going to have to sell some tomatoes first.
I got it.
10 cent rocks.
Someone's buying it.
Probably.
Immediately.
Any more rocks?
Any more big old stones?
Oh!
We have a back door here.
Good to know.
It's a little...
What's this room?
It's rusted shut.
Yeah.
That's the reason.
Whoa!
It's already starting to get so dark.
Shut the door.
I don't like this.
Check the painting.
I did.
It's still people looking at us.
Who is trading 10 rocks for a watering can.
Oh!
The window's open, you guys!
It's the window!
Huh.
Flush any bad spirits out the house.
Flushed.
Oh my gosh.
It's starting to get dark.
Why is the painting glowing?
Oh!
They...
Ah!
Wee!
Okay.
Let's go to bed!
Wait.
Can we turn the lights on?
Oh, thank God.
Oh, we got a nice little fireplace.
Light that up.
No?
Okay.
Never mind.
Why don't we have like a radio or something, you know?
I guess we can go...
Go to bed.
Okay.
Let's just go to sleep.
Let's go to sleep, everybody.
Oh!
Wait!
I cleaned up my room!
What is this?
Wait.
Huh?
What does it say?
Check.
Okay.
The ghost wants us to read.
Um...
This is all still the same.
Okay.
Good night!
Oh my gosh.
I thought something was gonna be on the ceiling.
How is this guy paying for utilities?
All right!
Day two!
All right.
Day one was pretty easy.
Good night!
Good morning, Minto!
What is that?
A sheep?
Have I already been blessed with...
What's my to-do list?
Collect tomatoes!
Buy...
Buy the build book.
Build a chicken coop.
Glowing animal.
I've been blessed with a sheep!
In the early hours!
We can now collect other stuff!
Good morning!
Oh!
The hand is gone.
All right.
Everything is fine.
Let's go check out our new...
Newly added...
We're gonna...
We collected the trash in our room, but we're just gonna ignore everything else in here.
It's totally fine.
Where...
Oh, maybe it was the other side.
This way?
The glowing animal.
Whoa.
The power company will accept 6,435 rocks.
Huh?
Oh, wait!
There's a person there, too!
What is that?
There's a person there, too.
Hello?
Oh, that's not a sheep.
That's a deer?
Oh.
And a ghost...
Person.
Lady?
Claire?
Whoa!
You remind me of something.
You remind me of someone, girl.
She can...
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
I thought...
I thought we were on the road for a second.
Are you gonna keep up or what?
Oh, sorry.
I'm sorry.
I just can't get over this view.
Wow.
I can't believe you've never crossed the bridge before.
Yeah, but why leave downtown anyway?
To come see me, obviously.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Sorry, Claire.
Probably the best point.
Hudson River.
Oh!
Is that a deer?
How did a deer get here?
How did she even get here?
Yeah.
Hold on.
Give us some space.
Oh, okay.
We've gotta help it.
Okay, I'm gonna help him.
Right now.
Oh.
Oh!
The deer turned into the barn.
It's okay.
Let's get you home.
Oh no.
Did we kill our wife?
Is that one of these situations?
Claire.
Do you ever think about me?
Oh.
She's alive?
Like I think about you.
Oh.
Do you ever wonder where I am?
Claire, I'm obsessed with you.
It doesn't matter.
Oh.
Get back to work, Garrett.
That's all you're good for.
Garrett's got some troubles.
That's okay.
We understand you, Garrett.
All right.
Oh my gosh.
Tomatoes!
He said tomatoes were worth a lot.
We collected 10 tomatoes.
Oh.
These are not market, you know?
These are not market.
These are like...
Wow.
People pay less for the deformed ones, you know?
Where did this axe come from?
Wait.
Now this should come in handy.
Five dollars for...
Wait.
We just got a free axe.
No way.
Jeez, ghost.
You live like this.
Your farm is filthy.
I just moved here.
I think.
Oh.
I just moved here.
Holy cow.
Okay.
I think I'm insane.
I think I'm a superhuman.
I'm carrying half a tree.
Don't destroy your fence.
And I'm walking very slowly.
I can't even sprint.
The music disappeared.
It's just us.
In the wilderness.
You know, when I see stuff like this, I'm like, yeah, maybe.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Only 50 cents for a tree?
Come on!
I think like, you know, when I see like this, I'm just like, Oh, baby, it would be so nice to just get away from it all, you know, to just like...
Oh, we have to build the build book.
But then I see at night and I'm like, you know what?
Never mind.
I think I'm fine living in my maid cafe where it's nice and bright all the time.
No idols.
There's be no nothing.
Hercules.
I know this guy.
He was built for the outdoors.
He can even jump!
He's insane!
Go, Garrett, go!
Okay.
How do I now build the build book?
Oh, we can get a rake?
Farming?
Build book!
Five dollars.
Okay.
Okay, you got this.
Just follow the instructions, bro.
Follow the instructions, bro.
What are we building?
What does it say?
To build a chicken coop!
Where do we want to put our chickens?
Probably away from the fence.
Garrett's talking to himself.
Who else can he talk to?
Garrett is lonely.
Garrett's...
Oh my gosh.
I'm like freaking out over like...
What if I see someone standing in my house?
Oh, is there not a fence this way?
Oh, so this is how we leave.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Wait, the fence is huge.
Oh, there's a path though.
Okay.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
This is another road.
I'm sliding.
Where does all this go?
Wait, does this...
Oh, I should probably build my chicken coop, right?
Are those wheat or grass?
Wheat, maybe?
Maybe we have all the farm we need, right?
Okay, let's build a chicken coop.
Build structures?
Oh, fencing?
Wait, how do I build a chicken coop?
Not in my build book.
In here?
Oh.
Chicken kit.
Well, I have to buy the kit.
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, the birds are...
Oh, the sun is...
Oh, the sun is going down.
Oh my god!
There is somebody in my house!
Oh, beep.
Okay, time to build the chicken coop.
Wait, structures?
Oh no, I need ten dollars!
Uh-oh, you guys, the sun is going down.
The sun is going down.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Um, my to-do list.
Build a chicken coop.
I think I have to build a chicken coop.
Oh gosh.
Wait.
Oh!
I'm scared.
Wait.
I don't want to go inside and I don't want to go outside.
Uh-oh.
Um.
Uh.
I'm scared.
Swing!
Bada-bada-bada-bada!
Do it tomorrow?
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna...
I'm scared right now.
Is this creepy music or good music?
This is music music.
Who's using this lookout tower, I wonder?
There's even a little flag on it.
Okay.
The music is coming from this direction.
Music coming from inside the house.
I think.
Oh my god!
I don't know what that is.
Um.
You guys?
I think there's something wrong.
I think, uh...
What's happening?
Um.
I think we should go to bed.
Shut the door.
Let's go upstairs.
It's not the TV.
Let's just go to sleep.
My to-do list isn't complete yet!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait.
Everything's red.
Um.
You guys?
I think I'm dead.
Oh.
I'm dead, dead, die, die.
Die, die, die.
Wait.
No, really?
Seriously?
I have to do my comp- Oh my god, no.
I don't even have enough money to make up!
I don't have enough money!
I only have six dollars!
Dead on day two?
Can I just wait for, um, for it to turn to day?
Oh, wait.
Oh!
Thank goodness!
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Oh, you couldn't see cause I was blocking it.
A bed appeared in the top left, top right corner.
Oh gosh.
That was spookiness.
I don't even know what was going on, but that was spookiness.
I did not like, I did not like that one bit.
I did not like that one bit.
Okay, it's back to normal.
Oh my gosh, it's back to normal.
Yeah, you hear those wolves?
We're building a chicken coop, but, oh, I guess this is okay now to go outside.
Let's get my axe, just in case there's any...
The birds are chirping!
The day is beautiful!
Oh my god.
Oh, that was really spooky.
Check the to-do list.
Build a chicken coop!
Okay, let's carry our logs, everybody.
That was fine.
That was, that was scary.
I don't know.
I don't know what was in the painting.
I wonder if something happens every night.
Like maybe something, like maybe a different monster happens each night or something.
Like the first night we had the hand and then this night we had the Babadook.
Forgot the water.
Wait, no, I watered, right?
Water?
Oh, water.
Water.
They're all watered.
All good.
Oh wait, there was, I think, what was it?
The rake, right?
Should I buy this and then plant more tomatoes?
Tomato seed.
Practically unlimited supply of seeds.
Ooh, use the rake to plant them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe.
One singular droplet for each tomato.
Okay.
Hmph, I wish I could move the trailer closer.
Do axes work on ghosts?
I can't say that they do.
But you know.
Oh gosh, when they chirped like that before, there was somebody in my house.
Come on, stop tripping over the logs.
See guys, this is just like Stardew Valley.
Where things come out at night, try to kill you.
Ooh.
I wonder who died here.
Old man Jenkins.
Oh no, can I not get that log because it's outside the fence?
Forgot my flashlight is on this whole time.
I can't get this log because it's outside the fence.
Oh man.
Yeah, just like in Stardew Valley.
Cut down the tree so it falls towards the cart.
Oh.
Are you a genius?
Wait, oh, I guess that worked.
Did that work?
Yeah?
Okay, let's try it, let's try it.
This way, right?
Tim!
Oh wait, it's gonna fall towards my house!
Timber!
Oh my gosh, genius, genius, genius, genius.
Genius!
Wait, where are you going?
Oh ho ho ho ho ho ho.
Now we should be able to build a chicken coop.
How much money do we have anyway?
$11!
All right, let's put this one in here.
Build our chicken coop.
Oh, no, sorry.
Build book.
Chicken coop.
Oh, it's $10?
Wait, I have to pay to learn how to build it and then pay for it itself?
That's ridiculous.
This is a nice area for the chickens.
Is that my room, right?
I can wake up and see the chickens every morning.
Oh, oh, what did I just do?
Wait, huh?
Oh, I just, there we go.
Okay.
Standing torch.
I'm gonna buy that, I'm gonna pay for this too.
To keep, this is Minecraft now.
Keep the mobs away.
You need to buy chickens.
Oh.
You're right.
Chicken!
Uh, what was it?
Oh, build.
Uh, here.
What was it on here?
What's, oh, carrying.
There's even upgrades.
Move 50% faster while carrying.
I have $5 only.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Oh, this is all stuff for the full game.
Interesting.
Okay.
Um, how do I buy chickens?
Are they under build?
Build chickens.
Oh!
$5!
I can only buy one chicken.
You're the chosen one.
You're the chosen chicken.
You!
You alive?
Are you good?
He's alive.
He's shell-shocked.
He's like, what?
How did I get here?
Oh, okay.
He's good now.
The wolf will love it.
No!
Let there be light for you, chicken!
Okay, I have to manually light these.
That's good.
Do they last all night?
Maybe?
You think?
Where'd he go?
Chicken!
Don't go, don't go too far.
Don't go to the...
Oh my gosh, my chicken's gonna leave me.
My chicken's gonna leave the farm.
Chicken, no, no, no, no!
Chicken, don't leave!
This fence is not...
This fence is not chicken-proof.
I think we're...
No, no, no!
No!
He's already trying to leave!
Chicken, no!
Chicken!
Chicken, please!
Chicken, I just bought you, please!
Oh, look, there's even like a little stick for like showing how...
Where's my plot of land?
There it is.
Does this light work?
Why doesn't that work?
So, we do have light...
Oh, gosh.
The crickets.
The crickets, the crickets, the crickets, the crickets.
The crickets, the crickets, the crickets.
What if I stay out, though?
I don't think I want to find out.
I'll be honest.
I think I have 2 chickens.
I'm more chicken than this chicken, I think.
Let's check our painting.
Since the...
Wait, where's the painting?
Oh here.
The painting is open!
The door is open!
The door!
Our house is on fire?
I keep forgetting to turn off the flashlight.
I'm so sorry.
The door is open.
And the door is closed.
Yeah.
Is our chicken gonna be okay?
He's not gonna get eaten though, right?
You don't think?
You think he's gonna be alright?
You think our chicken will be okay?
I'm kinda parasocial for him.
I think I saw a four-wheeler.
Oh!
I did see it!
It said that I need scrap to fix it.
Why is it lagging all of a sudden?
Oh wait.
I should probably hold this, right?
Destroy the painting.
Eek!
Okay.
Oh.
I hear footsteps.
Do you guys hear that?
What's that?
What was that?
I heard footsteps.
Oh!
It's a little... It's a little like moldy.
The black mold?
Okay.
I think actually our place is not haunted.
I think we have a lot of black mold.
And we are ingesting it.
You know?
Chickens?
Chicken.
Singular chicken.
Be good out there.
What is...
Be good out there, single chicken.
Look, the torches help with the mobs.
It's okay.
Maybe.
Can we sleep?
I haven't...
Okay.
There we go.
Ooh!
Heh heh.
What was that?
No.
No!
I guess I'll take a quick look outside.
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no.
I don't like that.
What was that sound?
Where do I go look at the sound?
Oh, no.
Hmm.
What does that mean?
Can't I just check from the window?
Can't I just be like...
Yep.
Nothing there.
Oh, gosh.
That doesn't look so dark out.
Maybe we're okay.
My tomatoes are grown.
Okay, guys.
I think this was a mistake.
This game is so spooky.
Actually.
Okay.
I did...
I'll be honest.
I did turn the gamma up.
Because, um...
That...
Oh.
Okay.
That sounds like a wild animal.
Right?
Oh, there...
There's a bird!
It's this bird!
Oh.
Turn that on.
And...
Oh, that light is on.
Okay.
Good to know.
It's a bird!
Oh, my God.
That's it!
Okay.
Go inside.
Come on, Garrett.
Get a grip.
Yeah.
Get...
The lonely nights can destroy you.
Nighttime in the forest...
Oh, gosh.
Can be...
Nothing here.
Can be especially dangerous.
You can avoid the night by finishing your to-do list and going to bed early.
You can also...
You can also clean your home and grow your farm.
The greater your farmstead grows, the more protected you will be from dangerous hauntings.
Inside.
You're a grown-ass adult, Garrett.
Yup.
There's no one out here.
Go and look around if you're so scared.
You, baby.
Oh!
Don't say that, please.
Is that my house?
Who's filming this?
You, voyeur?
What?
Oh, I can't turn it off?
Um...
Okay.
Beep, beep.
Yeah, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
I'm just...
Just collapses into the bed.
There was a...
Wait, there was a face?
A face in the corner?
Wait, what do you mean?
Hmm?
Are you talking about me?
I don't feel as alone as I used to.
I wish that wasn't the case.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I don't think that's a good thing, man.
I don't think it's a good thing that we don't feel very alone in our haunted house, okay?
Just saying.
Everything's fine.
I don't know why I feel so much more comfortable with the back door.
Oh, what's our to-do list?
Buy a better axe, explore the inside of the barn.
Oh, out there?
Gosh.
Good morning, Minto!
Check for eggs.
Yeah.
We got our tomatoes from earlier.
And eggies of our single...
Look at him go inside!
Oh my gosh!
You've been a busy plant!
Whoa.
Okay.
Single chicken.
All right.
And you're pooping out some more?
Okay, chicken!
Never mind.
False alarm.
Okay.
Let's go, chicken.
Let's go!
Two bucks!
And the music is over.
Oh, never mind.
All right.
Like I said, I think we should plant some more tomatoes, right?
Actually, let's get some more chickens.
Do eggs hatch?
Well, I only have...
one chicken.
$5 for that many!
Like...
We have $8.30 So...
The axe level 2 is $15.
Ow!
What if...
If I don't get enough?
Okay.
If I don't get enough, we're gonna...
We're gonna...
Not gonna be able to go anywhere else.
Oh gosh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Start cutting!
We need $0.50!
$0.50!
And we won't be able to go to bed!
It says complete your to-do list.
Like, remember how it said, like, You didn't complete your to-do list.
Oh, you're gonna get in trouble.
What's this sound?
Why is it so foggy today?
Where's our beautiful...
I don't like this.
Oh, to water.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So we can get more tomatoes.
Gimme dollar, gimme dollar.
Wow.
This is really how it would be, huh?
Just out here on the...
Little splash for you.
Splash for you.
I'm really...
I can't believe that works.
I was saying earlier though, I watched a little bit of some people playing.
That's why, like, I knew that...
Oh my gosh!
That's why I knew about the game and everything.
But their game was very dark, so I turned it up.
So that it would be easier, you know?
To see and stuff.
Okay!
$0.80!
Let's go!
Oh my gosh!
Where'd you come from, little guy?
I think I have a food bowl on the porch for you.
Oh, Michael!
Kitty visitor!
Wait, is that...
This one, right?
Kitty!
He's so cute!
Oh gosh, I'm gonna cry.
I miss my cat so much.
How much do we have?
Fourteen!
We're so close, actually.
Fifteen.
Okay, we need a dollar more, guys.
A dollar more.
We just gotta cut down one more tree.
Please let nothing bad happen.
Dev, if you're listening...
If you're listening, Dev...
There's rocks, too!
Don't let anything happen to the cat, please.
I wanna get more.
I wanna get more...
More chickens.
Cuz that chicken...
laid a lot of eggs, you know?
Look at him go!
You can see him walking around over there!
So cute!
Yay!
We can buy a new axe!
And now...
Okay.
I think I'm ready to venture out beyond the fence now.
Let's see what's out there.
Do I just break it?
Oh, you can break wooden fences with your new axe!
Oh, um...
We didn't need this fence anyway!
Okay!
Wow, it's really cloudy.
I'm kinda scared, though.
This place looks creepy.
Is there...
Okay.
Let's not...
Ooh!
Yeah!
Wow, this is incredible!
This'll be perfect for cattle.
For cattle?
Ooh!
I got metal!
Wow, this looks like pure zinc.
I read that an old factory is nearby.
Is that it?
That over there must be the old factory, right?
Oh, I was about to say, what is that?
But it's the chicken coop.
It's like glowing in the distance.
It's so brown.
Is it...
I can't tell if it's getting night time or not, you know?
All my stamina.
Zinc.
Let's sell this.
$30!
Why are we cutting down wood for pennies?
When I can just go and take apart a whole building and sell it for...
What?
$30!
Yeah, we can get more chickens!
Let's buy more chickens, let's buy more chickens.
Oh, wait.
It's under...
It's under here, right?
Livestock.
Chicken.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Chicken, chicken.
Okay, everybody!
Sounds like we had a great productive day.
I hear the crickets and it's time for me to skedaddle...
Our painting is fine, though.
I'm just gonna start stripping the electrical system for copper.
When are we gonna clean our house?
Doesn't feel very homey right now.
Look at them wandering.
Okay, don't go outside the fence.
Oh, shoot.
Maybe I should have rebuilt my fence.
Wait, we can build, right?
Maybe I should have rebuilt...
Oh, we can build a gate!
Okay, we're gonna build a gate.
Tomorrow.
We'll build a gate tomorrow.
Let's do any...
Let's go to sleep before anything scary happens, right?
There we go.
Prevent the evil.
Chapter complete!
New shop items unlocked!
Let's go.
I'm sure the chickens stayed.
What the hell do I do now?
What do you mean?
Oh.
To progress the story, go to the shop and buy an item marked with an asterisk.
It will start a sequence of important events and tasks which will lead to revelations about Garrett's past and future.
Yeah, the rifle, the rifle.
Completing chapters will also unlock new items in the shop.
Okay.
What do I do now?
I don't know.
You chose to live here.
I wonder if I can buy that rifle yet.
Buddy, it was a...
I just was able to buy chickens.
Please.
Give me a moment's break, okay?
Oh!
Pick up and sell all the trash!
Okay.
Finally!
Now that's what I'm talking about.
A clean home.
A nice chicken start.
Chickens...
Chickens are all still here.
We have three of them.
We should have three chickens, everybody.
Let's do a head count.
Only 25 cents?
Come on, man.
Okay.
Chicken one!
Do I... Do they need this clothes to...
Chicken two!
Do they feel embarrassed with this open, you think?
Chicken three?
Is that all of them?
Yup.
That's all of them.
All of our chickens are accounted for.
The whole family.
A dollar sixty.
Alright.
How much do we have?
Forty-four dollars?
Oh, hello, hello!
New items have been unlocked.
Oh, a grass hook.
Stamina.
Oh!
Okay.
We should buy...
We should buy these, right?
Our carrying speed would be good, because we...
Completely remove slowdown!
Why not?
Right?
Running speed...
Twenty percent.
Stamina by twenty percent.
Increased carrying load by ten percent!
Throwing power?
Increased throwing power for carried... Wait, really?
Some of these are still locked for the full game.
Oh!
The rifle is a hundred dollars!
Okay.
Um...
I think we need to, uh...
Save up.
Okay, we need to plant some more tomatoes, maybe.
Okay, okay.
And buy some more chickens, I think.
Feed the cat?
Okay, I'll feed the cat.
Let's go feed our baby.
Little baby.
Okay.
Tonight, guys, I'm gonna stay outside.
Tonight, we're going to push the boundaries of staying outdoors in the night.
Oh, nice!
I'm kind of scared, though.
Not kind of, I'm actually gonna be a lot of... Nice, nice, nice.
I'm gonna be a lot of scared.
Holy moly!
Oh my god.
Eggs.
Egg city.
Leave your eyes.
Ten million chicken flies.
There was, like, that grass hook?
I wonder if that will, um, work for, like, this stuff, you know?
It's ten dollars, though.
Oh, it's water?
Water and cans?
Oh, gosh.
I never have had to refill this thing.
You're probably supposed to water them properly, and here I am, like, giving them little...
They're working, though!
It's working!
Oh, wait.
Axe level two.
Does it work on this?
No.
Yeah, it does have a meter, but I think because I'm just getting absolute droplets, it just doesn't matter.
Wait.
Our pennies, our pennies, our pennies.
Watch out, cat!
I love this guy.
Oh, he's so cute!
Did you see?
He just went up, he just, like, he just, like, brushed against my leg!
That was so cute!
Okay, what's my other to-dos?
Oh, the trash.
And break up three tree stumps.
Okay, we're selling the logs, so we've been doing that.
Oh, okay.
Wait, but don't we want these to, like, regrow?
We're gonna run out of trees at some point, right?
Can't we cut down those trees?
And we're just gonna deforest the whole landscape?
That's okay.
We don't need a...
We don't need a forest.
Oh, this takes stamina, I just realized.
Okay.
Good to know.
We don't need a forest!
So maybe I should buy more stamina stuff, right?
Huh...
Okay, let's pick up and sell the trash.
Since there's a lot of this.
Pick up...
Trash!
Ew!
This is, like, my own- That can't be from, like, earlier.
Like, that's my own trash.
I'm just throwing my own bottles of beans on the ground.
Holy moly.
Okay.
Clean, clean, clean!
I like the...
You know, I like- The spooky aspect's fine.
Our painting is fine.
But, um...
Just, like, kind of the maintenance is also so great, you know?
I don't like having more than one door open.
This is very paranoid of me, but- Wait, the sun is already starting to go down!
Oh no no no no no no!
No no no no no!
Will it let me sleep?
Okay.
Maybe that- What was that?
Um...
Our painting is a little woozy.
Just means we need to put on our glasses, that's all.
That's all.
Danger is coming.
But what kind of danger?
What does woozy painting mean?
Wait, I'm 97% done with the trash!
Where's the rest- Where's the rest of the trash?
Our painting is... getting woozier?
Where's the rest of the trash?
Fireplace?
Oh, oh, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay, let's go do it.
Let's go sell it.
Okay.
Run, run, run, run.
You know what?
I said I was gonna stay outside.
I changed my mind.
I changed my mind!
As soon as the painting starts acting up, I start acting up!
But I wanna know what's out there.
Check the toilet...
It's fine!
Look at all this mold!
It's not us, it's the- Wait, it's- Is it upside down?
Or am I crazy?
Oh yeah, the painting is upside down now.
Oh, the fence gate!
My chickens!
You think they'll be okay?
Another day?
Oh no!
Oh, you can't see, but that noise is like a little bed symbol in the top right.
It's telling me to go to bed.
It's allowing me though, even though I didn't complete my to-do list.
I guess we're okay.
Is there anything else in my diary?
Oh gosh.
The chickens will be fine.
There's gonna be something on my ceiling, I swear.
Day 6?
There's gonna be something on the ceiling, you guys, I swear.
But what's out there?
I have to be brave at some point.
Maybe when I get closer to the end of me being able to play, right?
Okay, painting is fine!
Our house is clean, besides all the black mold that's investing my brain.
So far so good though, everything else is fine.
The light turns off and it scares me every time.
Look how beautiful it is!
Oh my gosh, chickens!
Don't make that noise, it scares me.
So far we've just had a spooky person in our house.
Whatever.
What else is in the barn, I wonder?
Okay, hold on.
We're gonna build this gate.
Oh.
Never mind.
Sell 12 logs.
But what if I went and explored Oh my yuck!
Six of the chickens!
We have the whole world now!
Like over here.
Oh, remember our map!
We have the map!
The map, the map, the map!
The sunrise is so nice.
I know, right?
I love when it's sunny.
And not ghostly.
Look, now we're just fire.
We're just watch the fire watch now.
Does all of this here land?
I'm not sure.
Okay.
Here we go!
Oh!
New location discovered!
We are at...
C2!
This doesn't look...
Actually, this looks quite modern, all things considered.
That fence looks extremely modern.
Why is our place such a dump?
All of this looks really modern.
Come on fat ass, you can do this.
Pog cameo!
Oh my god, C2!
I got a map of the area!
Our home, and the farm, and...
Everything else...
Is that all that's up here?
Really?
What is that over there?
Maybe for the full game?
And this is...
All items found!
Wow!
What's that crunchy sound?
Oh, the factory?
I think I can drop.
So I don't have to go all the way back down.
La la la la.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh.
Let's check out this fence real quick.
This looks like government facility.
Do not enter.
Secrets are being held here.
Oh.
Oh, we are being tested.
Guys, it's not haunting!
It's a government mind control trick.
Obviously.
Oh.
Yeah.
Let's get my axe back out.
I feel safer with this.
It's a government mind control trick.
We didn't explore everything in the barn, so...
Maybe there's some other stuff we can check out over here.
He said it was for cattle.
So maybe eventually we can get cows.
Sorry, I thought I heard something.
Like footsteps or something.
I want to see...
This game probably looks so much better with all the graphics at high.
Oh, climb?
Oh!
There we go!
Here I go.
What a thrill!
Cow-kini.
No!
Any more zinc?
Any more super expensive pieces of things to sell?
Wait.
Ammo!
More!
More ammo.
I'll take it.
Wait, what's up here?
I see something blue.
With darkness and silence in the night.
What is this?
An oil can.
Minto, do you smell anything?
Gas.
No, good.
That's good.
No, I think...
I smell that fresh, fresh air.
That fresh, fresh air.
These are rare items?
These rare items are not only used to buy the best items in the catalog shop, but are also required to complete the game!
Wait, you're making a rare item?
Keep an eye out for them as you explore.
You're making a rare item?
Something that you have to complete the game?
Okay.
Shit.
Shit?
What do you mean?
It's a puppy!
Wait, uh oh.
Is puppy not friendly?
Uh oh.
Oh, I think I'm surrounded.
Puppy is growling.
Puppy?
Where is puppy?
Um, where is puppy?
Puppy is gonna go after my chickens.
Oh!
Are you sure the cat was friendly?
Oh, there's two of them.
Oh shoot.
Oh god.
Um...
Uh...
Maybe we can jump and make a run for it.
Oh no, they're fast.
Oh my god, they're really fast.
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Wait, the sun is going down, you guys.
Uh oh, uh oh.
We gotta go.
We gotta go, we gotta go, go, go.
Oh, oh god.
Oh god.
Ah!
They're camping!
Okay.
I'm sorry, dogs.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry!
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
I'm sorry!
You guys, the crickets!
The crickets!
We're gonna go over there tomorrow.
Will it still let me sleep?
How's my painting looking?
Oh!
It's a tree!
I
hate nature.
Oh, my bad.
Not my house.
I'm destroying my house.
Do we still got them beans?
Oh yeah.
Um...
Oh no, we're gonna be haunted by the dogs.
Whoa.
It's so bright.
Why is it so bright?
Is it a full moon?
Whoa.
Okay.
That was nice.
Close the door.
No food for the cat!
It was right here, right?
We can feed the cat.
Oh, I didn't water my...
You guys, I didn't water my...
Oh my gosh.
It's a woozy tree.
That's the cat!
Food for you!
Goodnight, cat!
You wanna come inside?
You wanna come in?
You wanna like...
Not be out here?
Cat?
Come here!
Come on, cat!
There's food over here!
I'll just put the food inside.
The tomatoes?
Screw the tomatoes.
I hate tomatoes.
Guess we're good.
Oh my god, every time we lay down, it scares me.
The cat doesn't like mold.
Who wouldn't?
It's just extra flavor.
Okay.
Alright.
Another day.
Painting is okay.
Alright.
When I get closer to...
Oh my little baby.
Yeah, there you go.
I won't forget this time.
There you go!
That's not where the bowl is.
He's just standing in it.
You stand wherever you want, little cat.
Real cat behavior.
We still have tomatoes!
Even though I didn't water them?
Or did I?
Am I crazy?
Actually, I am.
I'm being poisoned by the government and by my house.
I think the lagging is...
um...
Is it because I'm on my laptop?
Because it does lag sometimes, but...
I think it's because I'm on my laptop.
You know?
Any dogs wanting to come over here?
Any dogs?
Okay, what's on our to-do list?
Oh, we still gotta sell those logs!
Wait, we can actually get this one now, though.
Good luck, Laptop-kun.
Oh, and let's get our eggs.
Let's get our eggs.
Eggs and logs.
Eggs and logs, everybody.
We're a farmer.
We ain't got time for no paranormal business.
Holy moly!
Okay.
The chickens have been really busy.
Oh my gosh.
Holy cow.
Eight dollars!
Let's go!
But he's laying another egg!
They're insane!
They're insatiable!
Am I getting all of them?
I can't tell.
Oh my gosh.
So many!
This is just three chickens.
Seven dollars!
How much do we have?
We can buy the rifle!
You guys, we can buy the rifle.
But that probably means like the real scary starts happening, isn't it?
Because it's a story thing.
What else?
We got our meds.
Aw.
Rifle ends the demo, I think.
Okay, we don't wanna get it quite yet then, right?
We wanna...
I wanna test out some of the other stuff too first.
A little bit.
I wanna test out some of the other stuff a little bit.
I wanna see more spooky.
Our cat is so cute!
Okay.
Don't roll, don't roll, don't roll, don't roll.
Don't roll, don't roll, don't roll!
Stop!
Stop moving!
Oh my gosh, please.
Okay.
Logs are making a break for it.
We're making good money.
We're making money, honey.
What's out in this way too?
Oh, there's another fence!
I did say today we were gonna go over to that place.
Well, I finished our to-do list.
We could go to sleep.
I think there's more dogs.
Dogs!
Let's not go over there.
Let's go this way.
To the infirmary.
I'm assuming.
There's another watchtower down there!
Well, you know what I probably should've done is bought more stamina.
Probably.
Take a swim?
I can't.
It won't let me.
Bloodlake.
Yeah, it's pretty nasty.
It's probably all rust from the factory.
And we're drinking this water!
You guys, we're totally poisoned.
We're just absolutely poisoned.
Three.
I don't think it's working.
Wait.
That's not... We don't have a lot of time.
Go, go, go.
Man, what is your story, old building?
Where's your loot, old building?
What was that?
Never mind.
I don't want to be in here.
Just kidding.
I'm leaving.
Okay.
I'm brave.
So, wait.
Oh, there's stuff in here.
Take it.
Go.
Oh, wait.
There's a... No, I didn't mean to drop it!
But this stuff's too...
This stuff too.
Okay.
Take it and leave.
Get out of here.
Let's go, go, go, go, go.
Sun's going down.
It goes down fast.
Hello, brave.
Hi, Minto.
I can only be one or the other.
This is a part for the bike.
Okay.
I got this.
Oh, it did say if we have the... Oh, I sold the first one though.
Maybe the cat is part of your imagination?
No, that cat is real!
It will vanish when you take your meds.
No!
Oh my god, crickets, crickets, you guys.
Crickets.
I did water.
Right...
Okay.
We're ready to escape.
What's that sound?
It's gonna sound like someone's sniffing me.
My cat's eating.
My cat is growing healthy and strong.
All good.
It's not like letting me interact with it, so I think it's a sellable.
It's only sellable.
Sniffle?
Oh my gosh.
It's getting dark fast, you guys.
It's getting dark fast.
Chickens, go to sleep.
Don't get eaten.
Be good chickens.
Throw!
Yeah.
How much money did I make?
Oh my god.
Get inside.
How's our painting?
It is... wobbly!
Stay up for the night!
What if I...
I was about to say, what is that?
It's my torch.
I was like, there's something glowing outside!
Stay up for the whole night?
My computer is really...
My computer is chugging, you guys.
I'm not gonna lie.
Do you think the cat will be okay?
Where is the cat?
Cat?
Oh!
There he is.
The cat is actually the danger.
The log...
What's that?
What does that mean?
What's going on?
Oh!
What's that?
Guys, I'm in danger.
Guys, I think we should go to bed.
Guys, I think we should sleep.
Smell that log.
Guys, I think we were in mega danger.
Oh.
Are we still in mega danger?
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
No, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
Feed the cat first and foremost.
Good morning, cat.
Come on.
Fill her up, baby.
Why do we have both axes?
I wonder what that was, though.
There's so much.
I'm too scared.
This game...
Oh, I want to see everything, but I'm too scared.
I want to see everything, but I just had the baby.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I think I just wasted my water.
I think I have to carry it first.
I think I have to pick everything first.
And then...
Water.
Stop being scared, VTuber.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Chickens.
You guys are killing it.
Please move.
So I can grab your babies.
Holy moly.
They...
They laid so many eggs.
They gotta poop out these damn eggs.
Count them before...
Oh, they're not hatching.
They're getting sold off.
161.
Okay guys, we got a lot of money.
So, what we're going to do?
We're going to buy stamina.
We're going to buy running speed.
We're going to buy a carrying load.
Oh, just one, not two.
We're going to buy...
this hook.
It's so expensive, you guys can matter more about it.
We're mowing the lawn!
We're mowing the lawn now!
Oh my gosh.
They did say like keep your place clean.
And...
And less hauntings will happen.
Oh, I gotta actually water now.
A little bleep for you.
Oh, hey chicken.
A little shower for you.
A little shower for you, chicken.
Okay, let's go refill this.
I'm guessing I use the sink.
Right?
Oh yeah.
What if you buy a goat and the goat eats the grass for you?
Wait, can I?
I think the only livestock I have are chicken.
We have a chicken fence, but they've been fine.
I don't think I need to...
I think it's a little dramatic, right?
Here, let's get rid of all this.
Let's clean up our lawn a little bit.
I wonder... Oh, the tall grass?
Maybe... Oh, watch out, chicken.
I wonder if...
It's like wheat?
And then we could start selling wheat even, you know?
Yes.
Clean.
Lawn.
We're mowing the lawn.
Look!
It looks so much more...
Habitable now.
Let's go try and cut a wheat.
Wait.
Let's go this way.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
There's wheat over here.
Wheat?
Is this wheat?
No.
This is wheat.
Is that the dog still?
Oh my god, the dogs are still here.
Oh, I'm sorry!
They have to remind me of my past.
Okay.
Oh.
Guys?
I don't think we get anything from that.
That's a little disappointing.
What's over here?
What's on our to-do list?
Oh, nothing.
Garrett's like, I have nothing left going for me in my life.
Oh.
I can't climb that.
Okay.
Is there not even a door?
Don't people die in these things?
The silos and stuff?
Right?
That's what that is, right?
A silo?
That looks really far, but I want to go to it.
This game is going to be huge then, right?
Because there's this fenced off area over here.
And then this...
Eventually, they're going to have to give us like a torch, right?
That like...
It's like a Minecraft or something for real, right?
Yeah, they're terrifying.
The silos?
Yeah, right?
It's going to be terrifying.
I'm going to be running.
And the days don't last that long.
Oh, gosh.
One thing, two...
Oh, watch out, chicken.
I'm mowing the lawn.
Watch out, chicken.
This will help me see my chickens better.
Right now, they hide in the grass.
No longer chicken.
It did say we'll get livestock.
So like cattle and stuff too.
Oh.
I heard someone breathing.
Hello?
Oh, it was me?
Oh, the low stamina.
Oh.
You're right.
Guys, let's go buy a gun.
Actually, no.
Ignite, ignite, ignite.
Why can't I take down the big trees?
The crickets are starting and that means trouble is afoot.
And my chickens are like so mad.
Get the eggs.
Holy moly.
Okay, let's sell these real quick.
I didn't mean to throw that.
What was that?
Our painting is...
Oh.
Oh, no, no, no.
It's this thing again.
The Babadook.
That's creepy.
Oh, what's that sound?
I hear it.
I hear it, you know.
My game is really starting to lag.
Okay.
I think it's time for sleep.
I think that's what that means.
Is it, like, after me?
Is that what that means?
Yeah.
Because it comes around and disappears.
I want to see it.
I want to see it!
Stardew Valley doesn't look like how I remember it.
Go outside.
But I don't have my gun.
Oh, my cat is right there.
I think it's gone.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
It's this way?
It's over here?
Is it me or does my vision get weird too?
Or am I crazy?
I can't tell.
Mint is the first to die in the scary movies?
No, I'm not!
There's nothing even here.
Oh, maybe it's in my room?
Do you guys see anything?
Nothing here.
He's terrorizing my chickens!
Good night!
Day nine!
I'm not the first type to die in scary movies because I don't investigate.
Why would I die if I'm not doing anything?
First type to die are the ones that are just like, hello?
I'm an unassuming person.
I hear a terrible, frightening noise.
I'm just gonna go check it out.
Me?
Never.
Oh my gosh.
Every time it gets me.
Alright.
You guys laid some eggs?
Thank you, thank you for your...
for your patronage.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, there's two chickens in there.
Are you guys both?
Are you guys...
Oh, now there's three chickens.
Please move.
All of them are right here!
There's a whole...
There's whole empty slots everywhere.
Just like, go to another...
Please.
Please, chicken.
Let me grab your eggs.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
At this rate, I'm just gonna keep hoarding...
money.
So...
I think it's time for me to feed him.
Buy a rifle and...
face my fears.
Confront my...
my worries.
Oh, there's been a log here the whole time?
Quite honestly...
Guys, can you tell that I'm scared?
Can you tell?
You can't even tell.
I bet.
Purchasing this item will start a sequence of events that culminates in the ending of the demo.
Are you sure you want to continue?
Okay.
We could do one of two things.
One, we could buy the rifle...
and do the sequence of events that ends the demo.
Or two...
we can die...
and then if the full game comes out...
I start from when I buy the gun.
That's the thing about...
you know sometimes like how if you do a demo...
you have to like replay...
I mean I guess at this beginning of the game hasn't been very long.
Hmm...
Let me water my plants.
Stay outside one night first?
Oh!
Cool.
What is that?
Oh.
Is that what I use to...
I just threw down my basket.
Why is my vision all weird?
Is it just me?
Oh.
It like looks...
There's like a...
It's like...
motion blur in the side.
It's more than usual, right?
Or is it just me?
No.
It's definitely more blurry than usual.
Am I losing sanity?
Is it because I was staring at the guy?
You think?
Oh!
Yeah!
It looks weird.
Oh my gosh.
That is so cute!
Hold on...
How's our painting looking?
It's fine though.
I'd rather not!
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
We did feed our cat, right?
Yeah.
It's a Vineyard.
It did say something about mental state.
It did.
Yeah.
Hmm...
It's the black mold.
Absolutely.
Probably bugged.
Oh, maybe.
Might be bugged, yeah.
Oh my gosh, no!
But he's at game comms!
We can't tell him!
Did I get this one?
There we go.
I think it's bugged.
A little bit.
It's kind of making me woozy a bit.
So maybe...
Maybe I should die to restart.
Or to get it fixed.
I wish I could chop this thing down.
For some reason, these little tiny trees, you can't chop them down.
We're mowing the lawn!
That's what makes us lose our sanity.
Manual labor.
But no!
This is really beautiful!
This game makes me want to never buy a house in the forest, ever.
When I was a kid...
We went to a cabin in the forest.
For the summer.
With me and my family.
And it had a laundry chute, right?
Which, it was a two-story cabin.
And the laundry chute...
Like, the room where I stayed with me and my sister...
We...
There was a little...
Hole...
That you threw your clothes down...
And it would go to the laundry room, right?
And...
So...
You know...
If my mom was doing the laundry...
She could hear, like, my sister and I...
Playing up in the room.
And...
One day, she heard me...
Like, talking...
And...
I, like...
I...
Was, like, having a full conversation.
And...
My mom thought...
I was playing with my sister.
But then she was like...
Wait...
Sister...
Went out with my...
With my dad.
So...
My mom...
Came upstairs...
To see if I was, like, playing.
You know, maybe I was, like, playing dolls or whatever.
And she...
Um...
She...
Goes...
Into...
The room...
And sees that I'm just sitting on the bed.
And, like, playing with my sister.
And, like, talking to the air.
And my mom was just like...
Minto...
Who are you talking to?
And I was like...
What do you mean, mom?
I'm talking to this man right here.
Isn't that so scary?
And my...
My mom...
Asked the...
The...
Um...
Owners of the place...
Later on...
She was just like...
She was like...
Um...
You know...
Has anything happened here before?
And they were like...
Oh...
Well, you know...
The...
The original owner...
Died on the property.
So...
Let's grab our little thingy.
Our little...
Oh!
We have a tomato!
So...
All right.
Now, run inside.
Wait!
Should I buy the gun?
No!
The original man.
Oh, it's getting woozy!
It's getting woozy!
It's always so woozy.
Oh!
Wait.
Is this the red night?
Remember how like...
Wait.
Maybe not.
Remember how one night it got like really red?
And everything was red and red and red and red?
You guys, I'm scared!
I don't want to stay outside.
I don't want to stay...
What's the other door basement?
Yeah.
But we can't go in there.
It's locked.
I want to keep my lock shut.
I kind of want to sleep, though, so we can get rid of this dizzy effect.
Just don't get scared.
Easy.
Oh!
It's like far away.
Interesting.
So, there's so...
So, there's other ways of the painting we still haven't seen yet.
I wonder how much is in this demo, you know?
It's kind of crazy.
You can like hear it, like, transforming, which is creepy.
Oh, I hear music.
Like an ambience.
Oh, I hear an ambience.
Stay up a bit tonight?
I'm scared of doing that.
Look at our chickens, they're going inside the coop.
Look at them go!
Oh, I got my little sickle.
Chickens are so brave.
Oh, a cat is looking at us!
He's so cute too.
Yep, enjoy your... why?
Oh my god.
We are not safe inside the house.
We are not safe inside the house!
Oh no, the blur is still there.
Wait.
Maybe not.
Maybe we're okay.
Also, yeah, we sent this letter.
Right?
Interesting.
Still haven't seen anything about that.
Buy the gun?
Okay, we're gonna buy the gun, everybody.
Let's buy the gun.
Wow, there's still so much in this game.
Good morning!
Oh my gosh, we can see our chickens so clearly.
Our lawn looks great, doesn't it?
It looks so...
It's so clean.
Our lawn is so clean.
Oh, it looks like our house is on fire.
And our cat.
Good morning, cat.
Kind of weird that the game encourages going to bed as a defense mechanism.
I don't think I would be able to in that circumstance, right?
Right?
I like that this game is so normal.
And then also, it's like, by the way, you're also being haunted.
This game feels like just a normal...
Like, I'm just cutting my lawn.
And it's like, oh, by the way, you're also haunted.
Cutting the lawn, cutting the lawn.
Yeah, it's still kind of glitched.
So, I shall buy the gun.
And...
As soon as I finish cutting this area.
Watch out, chicken.
Perfect.
Right?
There's this whole section area, too.
Oh, look!
I didn't even notice you were in here!
Okay, we gotta cut this lawn, too, you guys.
We gotta cut the lawn.
Stalling?
No...
It's actually just kind of relaxing of a game until...
It's not.
You know what I mean?
It's just kind of like, ooh, yeah.
Ooh, my computer's really chugging, though.
Okay, let's get this over with so my computer can rest.
Kind of cool, though, that there's still more that we haven't seen...
In the demo.
So, it makes me wonder how much is gonna be...
How much...
How much will there be in the...
In the game...
The main game, too, you know?
My computer's about to blow up.
Go for it, computer!
Go for it!
Fight!
Like, I just kind of like doing this.
Is it so wrong to want to just be a farmer on my little...
My quiet life as a farmer?
Alright, let's buy the gun.
Oh, wait!
Before we do that...
Voices of the Void?
Like, Outer Wilds?
Oh, I guess I know what you mean.
Where it's...
It's not scary until it is.
I get it, though.
But we've had, like...
We've seen, like, that person standing in my house in the middle of the day.
And now she's in my bathroom.
And now my sanity is low, low, low, I guess.
Better laptop fun.
I just bought this.
No, actually, it's been having a lot of, like...
I tried updating the drivers, but even still, like, it has been having a lot of issues.
So, I shall return it once I get home.
Finally, some good news.
A gun!
Fire...
Aim...
Little chicken.
We don't need eggs.
We need...
How do I put my gun away?
Okay.
We need...
We need meat.
Am I gonna have to start killing the chickens?
Wait, why do I need a gun?
I mean, I guess they're actually...
I don't...
I say that, but...
We've had a wolf problem.
So, uh...
Actually makes sense.
Checks out.
What else is there to buy?
So, we have the rake.
We haven't...
We've been okay on money where that we haven't really had to, like...
But look!
Eventually, that's a blind mower, isn't it?
Powerful auto-harvesting vehicle...
Okay, nevermind.
Sorry, the sounds really changed all of a sudden.
Okay.
What is this?
A simple wooden handle with nylon...
bristles?
A broom?
A brush for livestock?
And then, this is the ATV.
The four-wheeler.
It's a four-wheeler.
Our meds.
Throwing power.
I haven't really needed to use that either.
I guess that's good at night, if you're like...
Uh...
This is a mental enhancer?
Oh...
This is...
Caffeine?
Oh, maybe it makes you stay up at night?
Energy booster?
This is crazy.
Even stuff for the house.
Fabric?
Quality fabric?
Oh, look.
Oh, the furnishings package?
We can make this place really nice, actually.
This is a real fixer-upper, but we're gonna fixer-upper.
Right?
Yeah.
These chickens lay like crazy.
So, was there something on my to-do list?
Oh, shoot.
Five cans?
On the log pile.
Easy.
East of the house.
Oh, um, wait, but it's night time.
Um, east?
We haven't gone that way.
What is it?
Five cans on the log pile?
Wait, but, doesn't the sun...
Why isn't the sun supposed to set in the west?
That's west, but the thing is pointing... wait, you can see it, right?
You can see it's pointing east.
Um, developer?
Uh, let's go inside.
Did I feed the cat?
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, we did.
Okay, good.
There's food, there's food, there's food, there's food, there's food.
You did not feed the cat.
Yes, I did.
Look, there's food.
The sun is haunted.
The sun is not following conventional rules.
The ghost is manipulating everything.
Did you water the cat?
Oh, gosh.
Guys, I wanna be brave, I really do, but I'm scared of dying, honestly.
I'm scared of dying and, like, having to restart.
Well, if I die...
Okay, hold on.
If I die, I just start the day over again.
And we didn't really do anything.
Right?
We just, uh...
We just, um...
What's the word?
We just got the gun.
The farm must be in the southern hemisphere.
Oh, my chickens are so good.
They listen so well.
You know?
Okay, I'm gonna stand right here, guys.
Something, if something spooky is out here, it'll come to me.
Hey!
Ghost!
Oh, my God!
The spooky thing is the cat!
Uh-oh.
If there's something spooky out here...
It'll come to me!
Maybe.
Is there?
Let's check the painting.
Oh, sorry, I thought I just saw something.
It hasn't changed much.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Um...
Okay.
Uh...
I think I do need to go to bed.
Oh, God.
Oh, God!
Oh!
Ah!
Remember to go to bed on time to avoid losing money!
Oh!
What?
I passed out.
I lost three dollars.
Okay.
So that happened.
I didn't even stay up that late, though.
Right?
I feel like that was pretty nice.
It's pretty normal time.
The ghost robbed me.
Wow, the birds in the distance are so beautiful!
Oh, this game is probably so awesome on, like, high-quality graphics.
I wish I were home.
I should have played this when I was home.
The ghost steal three dollars from you?
That's a lot of money in my little ghost economy.
Okay.
That's a lot of money!
Did you see how much eggs costed me?
Wait.
But...
I think maybe I was staying up too late.
I'm guessing.
Because the motion blur is gone.
So maybe... it was that.
I was staying up late.
And...
And it was a... like I just had low tolerance at that point.
Guess I better go to bed now.
Alright, let's water this and then we'll go shoot some cayennes, I guess.
We haven't been to that area, so...
The ghost stole three dollars from me.
How funny.
Oh my gosh, I thought I just saw someone standing there.
That scared me.
I think it was just my imagination.
Oh, let's feed the cat.
Hey cat!
Oh, um...
Our backyard looks awesome.
I guess this is technic-
Why is it woozy already?
It's daytime!
What are you talking about?
It's woozy!
But it's daytime!
Oh no, no, no!
Why is it woozy during the day?
Three cans on a log east of the...
This way?
These cans?
Uh oh.
You gotta be kidding me.
I'm sorry.
We'll just never mow the lawn here.
Oh my god.
Did I do it?
Yep, I shot the cans.
What else is down here?
Oh, another fence.
Okay, yeah, the government is testing us for sure.
Why is our whole property fenced off with this, like, industrial fencing?
Our ghost made... oh.
I'll never leave here again.
So the gate stays locked.
Only the county flatbed hauler comes and goes.
What?
This must be the work of the phantom thieves!
Look how beautiful it is here though.
This is actually... wait, can we chop down these trees?
No.
I think maybe we get a better axe and we'll eventually be able to?
Deforestation!
The whole place!
How did the wolves get in?
They jumped.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh, I thought this was someone behind the tree again!
It's the tree itself!
Oh my god, that scared the bajonkas out of me.
Okay.
Well, um...
We can go to bed if we wanted to, I guess.
Middle of the day, who cares?
Oh my god!
No, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm just trying to take your eggs...
And sell them.
For big money.
I love my chickens.
They give me so much money!
My chickens are awesome.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
More egg, more egg, more egg.
Just looking around.
Just looking at my property.
I'm a property owner.
It's pretty impressive, you guys.
Actually, the most impressive thing is that the wolves haven't eaten my chickens.
I can imagine, probably in the full version, that that might actually become a problem, right?
Like, that might actually be...
A thing.
Let's open up some extra ways to, like...
Go inside.
Wasn't there another path?
Oh, wait, this one right here, right?
You are really not a dog person.
The game forces me!
The game forces my hand!
What is this way, even?
Do you think I have time?
Okay, we'll check this out tomorrow.
Maybe.
But that was your fence.
Yeah, but I can't hop over it.
Here.
Since we're here...
Let's make this area so beautiful.
Let's cut the grass and make it lovely.
This is the front door, technically, right?
Is it still woozy, I think?
Why is it so woozy?
It's daytime!
Daytime!
Uh-oh.
I heard it.
I heard it transform again.
Oh, it's...
Open.
Whatever that means.
What time is it?
Evening?
Cone bar noir?
It's becoming...
The evening now?
I guess we'll go to sleep.
Otherwise...
Otherwise, we just pass out and lose my...
$41.
What if the more you pass out, even, the more money they steal from you?
The ghosts taking your lunch?
Oh, my God.
The game is really lagging.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
It's not the game.
I promise.
It's my computer.
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
But good night, cat.
Good night.
Wait, it's normal.
It's normal, though.
I'm hearing stuff.
I'm scared of the bathroom.
I can't even pee in peace.
Everything is bad.
Well, let's go to bed because we finished our to-do list.
So, let's just go to bed.
The basement, I don't think...
I think it'll let us know when we can go into the basement.
We cannot.
I think it...
I think this is the type of game that will be like, Oh, I can finally go into the basement.
Was this always peeled?
Was that always that bad?
I like that we lay sideways in bed.
Day 12.
Uh-oh.
Oh, the wolves got him.
And you said they'd provide the witness, right?
The wolves got him.
Yeah, they said it's not ideal, but we can just grab someone from the tax office.
I'm a baby now.
I'm a baby.
Oh, I can't believe we're doing this.
Oh, I think he's waking up.
Hm?
Oh, shh, shh, shh.
It's okay, Garrett.
You keep resting, sweetie.
I'm Garrett.
We got a ways to go.
I'm a baby.
I'm a baby now.
Okay, we're here.
Dad.
You scoop him up.
He'll wake up on the way.
Why am I pretending to be asleep?
Okay, I got you, bud.
I got you.
It's okay.
Oh, oh, Dad.
I'm sorry I was gone for so long.
Oh, my God.
Dad.
I won't leave you again.
What are you...
I can't move.
Hello.
Dad.
When are you getting here?
Did you get my letter?
Oh, the letter we sent.
I'm just so tired.
I have so many years left.
Dad.
What am I gonna do?
Maybe coming out here wasn't a good idea after all.
I can't go back.
I'd rather die than go back.
Voice acting in this is pretty good.
Good morning, chickens.
Oh, oh, oh.
There's people.
Oh, my God.
There's people in my lawn.
What are you doing on my lawn?
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh.
There's ghost in my lawn.
Wait.
There's a lot of people here.
Do you think this is the wife I probably killed?
Hey!
Hey, you!
I'm gonna buy it.
I'm gonna buy the running upgrade so I can come see your face.
I scared them away.
Is this one over there?
No.
Oh, there's...
There's a lady in the woods.
Get off my lawn!
There's music even.
Is this Death Stranding?
I know, with the music and the rain and everything, it feels like it.
This is very Death Stranding core, huh?
Just get to the end of the day.
Oh no, we're depressed, you guys!
Our farm is not good enough, I think.
I'll keep cleaning up.
Let's get to the end of the day.
The voice acting in this is really good, though.
Like, actually.
So far, I really like what it's got going for it, because it's like...
Like I said, it's just a normal farming simulator, and then...
And then ghosts.
Our cat!
Let's go feed our cat.
That will keep us motivated.
Our pet!
Yeah!
Our little kitty visitor!
This keeps us motivated.
To continue.
We gotta wake up so we can feed him, right?
Right!
This is so depressing, actually.
I think I'm going to be so baby, though, exploring this world.
Knowing that there's going to be issues at night.
But!
I have to... I have to know.
I have to face...
I really have to face my fears, you guys.
Okay.
I have to face my fears.
I have to go out.
I have to...
Because...
Because there will be times when I go outside, exploring the big world, and there will be ghosts, and I have to see them!
It's not just tears, it's the rain.
This is, I guess, not copyrighted music, because...
I switched that off.
Oh!
Alright.
Okay.
This is the second time.
Look at our lawn.
It looks so good!
It looks so clean!
It looks so clean.
Actually...
But I'm happy.
You can face your fears when you aren't depressed.
You know what?
So true.
Holy Moly.
This...
This is so...
What if I get two more chickens, you guys?
We will be having...
I think we're just a straight up chicken farm...
At this point.
We don't need to farm anything else.
All we have are chickens.
And we're good.
Oh my god, he laid another egg!
Look at all these chickens.
I'm gonna buy more chickens.
I did it.
I said I would and I did.
Oh my god, two more eggs!
Look at all my little chickens.
Oh my god.
Get out my crops!
Oh, I need to buy a scarecrow.
Oh, oops.
Those eggs are definitely fine and not broken at all.
I need to buy a scarecrow!
Okay, wait.
Where is it though?
Is it still in here?
I'll be honest.
Oh, farming.
I haven't been wanting to buy it because look how terrifying this thing is!
Um, hello?
I don't want to buy this thing!
It's so scary!
He laid another egg.
I'm gonna get scared by my own scarecrow!
He ate...
He ate... No, he ate one of my tomatoes!
I was supposed to have three!
Just get to the end of the day.
Our poor guy.
Come on, Garrett.
It's okay.
Um, what is it?
Oh, cue.
It's okay, Garrett.
Even though it's raining, we're still watering our plants.
I guess the rain doesn't really do anything, huh?
Still gotta water them.
Watch out, chickens.
I'm mowing here.
Doing my farmer duties.
Just the sound of the rain.
Sound of our chickens.
A little cat wandering around.
We have a really good place going here.
Ignore the ghost lady that sometimes appears in my bathroom.
Just like me.
You know?
Ooh.
I think that's our depression.
I think that's why.
Flush the spirits!
I fed the cat, right?
Yeah.
I guess it's night?
Cause it's...
Um... Yeah.
I hear crickets.
It's kinda hard to hear them.
Good night, everybody.
Oh, the sun's going down.
Check the fridge?
For our beans?
That's why we're depressed!
We're just eating beans every day!
We're eating beans and...
Beans and tomatoes every day!
We have... We don't even have chairs!
Okay, we made it to the end of the day.
Time for sleep time.
It's okay.
We'll go to sleep.
We'll go to sleep for you, Garrett, since you're depressed, you know?
Oh my goodness.
Follow me!
Holy goosebumps all down my spine!
What do you want with me?
Can't I just live here in peace?
Is that too much to ask?
It's not the ghosts that are making you depressed, Garrett.
It's the beans.
Something wants me to follow it to the shed.
North-east of the house.
She sounded cute.
I'd do it.
Oh!
Our bed is gone!
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Okay.
Um...
Oh!
There we go.
Shed north-east of the house.
North-east, right?
Yeah.
So...
That way.
Oh my gosh.
I thought that was... This little...
Like the handle, I thought was eyes staring at me.
Oh my gosh.
Holy cow!
This game is making me nervous!
Um... Next page.
This map is going to be humongous!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, this is our first time traversing outside, you guys.
I'm gonna take the axe.
I don't know.
I know the gun is great and all, but I feel more safe with the axe.
The game be lagging.
Wait, so this way.
That trail, probably, from earlier.
I'm scared!
I'm scaa- Wait.
Where is the path anyway?
Well now you can see the home from here.
Is the painting okay?
Okay, the painting is just our depression.
Oh!
Cat!
If I don't make it back, buddy... If I don't make it back...
Eat all the chickens, okay?
If I don't make it back, you are allowed to eat the chickens.
I give you permission.
Just let them fertilize the eggs!
And keep eating the chickens!
Where's the... It's this way, north?
Okay, I see the path.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't wanna go out.
I don't wanna be out here.
I'm saving my stamina for now.
I didn't even know there was a shed over here.
We didn't follow the path.
I don't even know there was anything out here.
Is there any... Oh!
Is there any zinc?
To sell?
You think?
What's in the shed?
I'm gonna shed myself right now.
Oh my god, please.
No!
I'm scared!
It's all on your head, Garrett.
Stop being such a little bitch.
You lunatic.
Okay.
Stop it!
Don't be mean to me!
Gosh.
Garrett's calling me a little bitch, you guys.
He's calling me a little bitch!
I'm so scared!
Oh gosh.
And the TV has a god in me!
Oh my god, I'm scared.
Oh.
Numbers.
Okay.
Prove him wrong.
Just runnin', swingin'.
I should've bought more stamps.
Stamina.
How much stamina do I have?
Oh.
Okay.
Nevermind.
I don't know.
Okay.
I'm going in.
What is this?
Read?
Look.
Back away.
But don't look too long.
Okay.
I'm going.
What am I looking at?
Oh, my heart's beating.
Oh, my God.
Uh-I think there's children.
I think there's children trying to kill me.
Oh, my God.
Oh, back away.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, my gosh, oh, my gosh, oh, my gosh.
But don't look for too long.
Okay.
Where's my house?
Oh, my gosh.
The children.
But don't look for too long.
My house.
Close the door.
Oh I heard them running, I heard them running, I heard them running!
What is that?
Oh my god.
Hello?
My game is lagging so bad.
Claire?
I'm so sorry.
Is that my... Is that my wife?
She's kinda...
Is
that a baby?
What was going on?
What's happening?
My whole
body is so tired.
Oh my gosh.
Full game includes new tools, crops, vehicles, and haunting enemies.
One square mile of land to explore, crafted with love.
Oh look, there's a little... That's a little goat!
Maybe we do get a goat after all.
An emotional 4 plus hour story with an unforgettable ending.
Bonuses like endless mo...
Endless mode, dev commentary, and more!
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, it's a little lamb.
You know me.
This land...
Oh, oh.
Wait, this looks like the eyeball that was in that note.
This land would be completely barren.
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna wishlist this though.
I'm gonna wishlist it for sure.
I'm gonna play with somebody because I'm too scared to play by myself.
So, I don't think we harvested any shadows.
But we sure did get a bunch of eggs.
My cat!
Oh, my cat's okay.
Too scary for me, Dayo.
That was so scary.
Fun, cozy little game.
Absolutely.
Goodness.
We harvest eggs.
This isn't as good of a time.
That's me though, right?
Coming inside.
Maybe I should have worded that differently.
Never thought I would see a combo of Silent Hill and Harvest Moon.
Thanks for the stream.
Yeah!
It is definitely...
It is a harvest.
But it...
Yeah, it's a Harvest Moon and Silent Hill.
It's like a very...
Yeah, I think that's probably the best way to put it, huh?
It's like Harvest Moon, but you're already married and you don't even know what you're doing and your wife jump scares you.
But also, the wife was like decapitated, right?
In...
In that...
In that room.
She was all...
She was all greened out and decapitated and freaky looking.
But he talked about her like she's alive.
He was like, do you ever think of me?
So, I don't think it's like a Silent Hill situation.
Hopefully.
Thanks for the Mario Maker.
We'll see.
No head versus too much head.
Those...
Those twins that were after me, definitely no head.
They were like...
They were...
They were coming at me with no head, for real.
And like half of no body.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Will be interesting to see what the full story ends up being.
Yeah, definitely.
Curious.
Very curious.
Indeed.
Like that it's more of a psychological horror site instead of jump scares.
There were...
The...
The scares were sometimes very subtle too.
Like, I think...
If I hadn't turned around and seen the lady walking through my house, I wouldn't have seen her.
And...
A little bit of it was more subtle, for sure.
I think.
Yeah, it gets in your head.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought there'd be more random scares like this.
Like, mortuary assistant.
But it's actually more comfy than I thought.
Yeah...
Comfy.
I guess we'll see...
This is just the demo.
So we'll see how the full version ends up being.
Because...
Um...
Could be.
Could be...
Could be!
We don't know.
But from what I saw of other people playing it, the demo seems promising, you know?
So I was just like, okay.
I do want to try this.
And!
Um...
Hold on.
I wonder if it's like your options.
Look!
There's so many different languages!
Yeah, there's so many different languages.
I think more people will... lots of people can play.
Hopefully I get to flesh out my role more in the full game.
There is no moon language.
The moon ruins are right here!
But this was fun!
Good place to end it because I gotta get ready to go meet with my friends!
So thank you guys!
I hope you enjoyed the demo.
Whenever it comes out, we'll probably play it.
Maybe not like day one, but eventually.
Oh, let me wishlist it real quick.
Wee, wee, wee.
Wee, hover shuttles.
Weep, weep, weep, weep, weep.
Hold on.
It's trying to play.
Uh-oh.
Uh, guys?
Am I still streaming?
My computer just froze.
Um, actually... Steam just froze?
Uh-oh.
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
Add to your wishes.
Oh, sorry.
It's playing the trailer.
Shut up.
Yay!
Okay.
Did I freeze too?
Freeze!
Hold on.
Let's play Red Light, Green Light.
Okay, I'm gonna close my eyes.
And when I open my eyes, the chat needs to freeze, okay?
When I close my eyes, when I close my eyes, you guys can chat.
When I open my eyes, you guys have to freeze, okay?
Okay, okay.
Green Light!
Red Light.
I think the delay kinda hurts this, doesn't it?
Oh!
Oh my god, it mostly froze.
Whoa, it slowed down a ton!
Green Light!
It actually slowed down a ton!
Red Light!
We kinda suck at this.
Yeah, you do.
I like how you guys are boxes.
Boob!
You're out!
Cool.
No, the chat is supposed to freeze, you guys.
The chat is supposed to freeze.
Anyways, okay.
I'm gonna go get ready and go touch grass.
Thank you guys again!
And I will see you guys tomorrow?
Am I streaming tomorrow?
I can't remember.
I think I am.
I believe I am.
Yes.
Oh, I played War of Holocure!
Yippee!
Okay!
I'll see you!
Oh, wait.
I plan on streaming.
Actually...
So Matara is spending the night?
You might hear Matara tomorrow morning.
Or I guess it will be tomorrow night, right?
Since I stream in the mornings for me.
But night time for maybe most people watching.
So it...
Yeah.
She's spending the night.
But...
Yeah.
Okay.
Anyway, thank you guys!
Thank you!
I'll see you guys later!
Bye bye!
I hope you enjoyed the demo!